Love it or leave it, Suicide Squad ushered
a ton of DC Comics' zaniest characters onto
the big screen for the first time—and gave
each one a makeover in the bargain.
While some stayed closer to their comic appearances
than others, there were a few Squad members
who were left completely transformed.
Here's how the Suicide Squad should really
look...
Captain Boomerang
Just like in the comics, Captain Boomerang
is not really an upstanding guy.
Aesthetically, though, the Captain's live-action
portrayal diverges significantly from his
original form.
Now there are probably no more ridiculous
outfits than his original boomerang-print
tunic and tiny hat, so new Boomerang is a
welcome departure.
The on-screen version is based more closely
on Boomer’s modern costume, so they both
wear a similar grey-blue peacoat and both
have a knack for throwing boomerangs...which,
for the record, are the worst weapons of all
time.
I can't believe I said that as an Australian.
"Oh no!
It's coming back this way!"
"That throwing stick stunt of yours has boomeranged
on us!"
But Jai Courtney's version has urbanized clothing
and jewelry.
His hair is not the orange of his comics counterpart,
but he does occasionally wear the knit cap.
Courtney also extended the character's usual
sideburns into fuller facial hair and snuck
in a little eye makeup to boot.
El Diablo
The fiery essence of Chato Santana, or El
Diablo, was definitely not lost in translation,
but there were still some noticeable style
changes with his ink.
In the comics, he has the swirl designs that
emphasize his flame theme.
With Jay Hernandez in the live-action role,
the character’s skin art is changed to a
scattered slew of new symbols that paint him
as a true tough guy.
Among his new markings are hash marks on his
eyebrows and a skeletal teeth design featured
on his upper lip, as well as a grim reaper
scythe on his forehead to show he's in the
business of death-dealing, even whilst on
his journey of repentance.
Katana
Superheroine Katana has worn multiple costumes
over her various TV appearances.
But when she first appeared in comics in 1983,
she had a red-and-yellow costume with ridiculous,
pointed shoulders and fur-topped shoes.
You know, the least stealthy martial arts
costume possible.
Over time, she toned it down into a red-and-gold
armor deal with a domino mask, but it’s
Katana’s completely revamped New 52 look
that appeared on screen.
Karen Fukuhara's rendition of Katana still
changes things up in a few key ways.
Her screen costume is a bit more conservative
than the skin-tight leotards Katana wears
in the comics, instead opting for a loose-fitting
plain t-shirt and pants.
She also doesn’t have traditional samurai
shoulder guards, instead wearing a varsity-style
jacket featuring floral tributes to her heritage.
Even with these changes, Katana is still pretty
recognizable.
Slipknot
One of the most significant design departures
in Suicide Squad can be found in Adam Beach's
version of Slipknot.
The movie's costumes crew almost totally dumped
the character's comics appearance: a full,
muscle-hugging bodysuit with bizarre side
windows, loose sleeves, and a mask.
In the movie, Slipknot got a much more militaristic
suit.
Gone was the corny noose design on his chest.
Instead, he was decked out in useful utility
gear and a built-in rappelling harness.
And his hair was tied back to look like—what
else?—ropes.
Can’t say the guy doesn’t have a theme.
Too bad he was only on-screen for about three
minutes.
Rick Flag
Joel Kinnaman's interpretation of Rick Flag
is relatively faithful to the modern version
of the character, but there are still a handful
of small style changes.
As a member of the U.S. Army's Special Forces,
the comics version of Rick Flag keeps a close
shave most of the time, whereas the movie
version has a little more going on under his
nose.
Kinnaman's also a living, breathing human,
so he’s a little less beefy than the Flag
familiar to DC readers.
However, just like his paper-bound predecessor
in the role, Kinnaman's take tended to wear
the same Army green jumpsuit and battlefield-grade
arms.
And of course, the low-guard buzz cut that
serves as a not-so-subtle salute to his military
service.
Amanda Waller
Just as in the comics, Amanda Waller is the
tough assembler of Task Force X who, in actress
Viola Davis' words, is a "big powerful black
woman, hard, ready to pick up a gun and shoot
anyone at will."
Unlike many of the other characters in Suicide
Squad, Davis' version of Waller bypassed DC
Comics' rebooted New 52 rendition of her character
and went all the way back to her earlier,
more business-oriented look, like in her 1980s
Legends debut.
Her pearls and hairdo, for example, were pretty
close replicas of some of her earliest appearances.
The Joker
While Jared Leto's version of the Joker adopted
some of the comics' version’s physical characteristics,
it was also a new take on the character in
several noticeable ways.
While Leto did keep the Joker's bright green
'do, he slicked it down, instead of the more
unkempt approach often favored by the classic
Joker.
Leto's Joker ushered in the era of the character
with grilled teeth and threatening tattoos.
And while we don’t get to see Joker’s
bare back, set photos and statues based on
the movie revealed a dragon tattoo that looks
pretty similar to the one Joker has in All-Star
Batman and Robin.
Even his signature purple coat got a biker-friendly
update.
Rather than the playful suit styling of old,
he had a shiny alligator skin number and went
shirtless beneath, just in case people wanted
to see that he wrote his own name on his stomach.
You know...just in case he forgot, or got
lost at the mall.
Harley Quinn
Margot Robbie hit a home run as the bat-wielding
Harley Quinn, but the character is hardly
recognizable as the one that debuted in Batman:
The Animated Series.
The old Harley Quinn looks like a straight-up
jester, which we got to see onscreen during
the Suicide Squad for one hot second, but
it's the later versions of the character that
lent a great deal to Harley’s movie look.
Robbie is a postmodern punk complete with
colorful pigtails, messy makeup, tattoos,
and a get-up that should appeal to cheerleaders
and biker chicks alike.
The pigtails are borrowed specifically from
Harley’s appearance in the video game Batman:
Arkham City, and the tattered t-shirt is pure
Injustice: Gods Among Us.
And we can thank her New 52 solo title for
those shorts.
Killer Croc
The appearance and origin story of Killer
Croc have changed so many times over the years
that there’s really not one “true” Croc.
But the guy we see in Suicide Squad is surprisingly
true to his very first full appearance in
Batman #358, where he’s just a guy with
a skin condition.
During his first appearance, he showed up
in a standard mobster trenchcoat-and-hat ensemble.
In Suicide Squad, he’s wearing a hoodie,
which is pretty much the modern equivalent.
As time goes by in the comics, Croc slowly
devolves into a more brutish, animalistic
villain, sprouting a tail and long reptilian
snout, so while the cinematic counterpart
seems to be a relatively regular guy now,
the future isn’t looking too bright.
Sorry, dude.
Deadshot
It's hard to hide a face as marketable as
Will Smith's, so it's no wonder the Suicide
Squad version of Deadshot doesn't often wear
his trademark mask.
When he does put it on, the on-screen version
flips the script and places his fancy sight
over Will’s left eye, whereas comics Deadshot
favors the right.
It’s a relatively small difference compared
to the big picture, however.
On screen, he wears a uniform that looks like
riot gear, and his usual red-and-silver costume
is nowhere to be seen.
Also, Floyd Lawton has traditionally been
a white guy with a doofy little mustache.
Honestly, we prefer the Fresh Prince in this
instance.
(rad Fresh Prince snap)
All of this, however, is light years away
from Deadshot’s first appearance in 1950,
where he looked like a stage magician, top
hat and all.
He tangled with Batman once and disappeared
until 1977, when he took on his more modern
look...which is still nothing like what we
see on screen.
Enchantress
In the comics, Enchantress receives her powers
after wandering off into a creepy room at
a mansion party and talking to a fat magic
head in a giant chair, because why not?
After blonde, bob-haired June Moone transforms
into Enchantress, she looks like a standard
sexy Halloween witch: green pointed hat, long
cape, miniskirt, and thigh-high boots.
Later, as she loses control of her powers
and turns a little evil, she dons an emerald
green halter top and gold band fitted around
her head, with occasional returns to her old-school
look.
In Suicide Squad, Enchantress is an archaeologist
who gets her powers from an ancient relic.
Whatever got under her skin in that creepy
old temple also gave her a complete, gross
makeover, making her far more dark and grungy
than her comics counterpart, only cleaning
up a bit when her powers are at full force.
The onscreen Enchantress, played by Cara Delevingne,
wears a hunter green swimsuit and crescent
headdress, a weird shadow of her comics counterpart.
And, for some reason, the filmmakers decided
to make her look kinda like Pigpen from Charlie
Brown.
Good grief.
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know which
costume upgrade you like the most…